[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 j'espère que
vous avez passé de belles fêtes de fin
d'année et que l'année 2023 commence
bien pour vous nous sommes le mercredi 4
janvier voici le programme faciliter
l'accès à l'information sur les
thématiques de l'emploi de la formation
pour les jeunes c'est l'objectif du
dispositif la boussole des jeunes lancé
au Mureaux en décembre dernier il s'agit
d'une première expérimentation avant
d'être déployée sur le territoire des
Yvelines nous en parlerons avec nos
invités Laurence cousin et Salamata
bianzo Mateta de l'association Yvelines
infogène depuis dimanche 1er janvier les
préservatifs masculins sont désormais
gratuits en pharmacie pour les moins de
26 ans une annonce du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron dans un
contexte où les maladies sexuellement
transmissibles sont en augmentation en
France mais alors comment en bénéficier
comment est-on remboursé le directeur
d'achat prévention santé nous aidera à y
voir plus clair et comme chaque mercredi
nous parlerons de cinéma dans votre 7-8
quels sont les films à ne pas manquer
cette année tirailleurs Barbie ou encore
Astérix et Obélix l'Empire du Milieu
nous ferons le point avec notre
journaliste Michael helmidoro au
programme également le coup de cœur d'un
professionnel du 7e art pour vous
replonger dans des classiques et avec
moi en plateau Régine ralès journaliste
de la rédaction de TV 78 vous allez nous
présenter les informations du jour dans
les Yvelines alors de quoi est-ce que
vous allez nous parler alors bonsoir
donc à l'approche de l'épiphanie nous
allons parler de la meilleure galette
des amandes des Yvelines mais nous
parlerons également de la soirée Mister
France qui aura lieu à Poissy et du
premier bébé né dans les Yvelines en
2023 et ce sera dans quelques instants
alors restez avec nous avec nous
également un plateau Laurence cousin et
Salamata bianzo Mateta bonsoir bonsoir
Laurence cousin vous êtes la directrice
d'Yvelines info jeune et Salamata
bientôt ma tata vous la présidente la
première question est-ce que vous ne
pouvez nous présenter cette association
qu'est-ce que Yvelines infogène alors
une information jeunesse où il vit une
infogène un nouvelle marque j c'est un
réseau national déjà c'est un label
d'État et nous renseignons les jeunes
sur tous les sujets qui les intéressent
sur le département des Yvelines nous
avons 32 structures labellisé infogènes
d'accord et donc en décembre dernier
vous avez lancé le dispositif la
boussole des jeunes on en parlera plus
en détail tout à l'heure dans quelques
instants avec nous également Jérôme
André bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur d'achève prévention santé la
gratuité du préservatif pour les moins
de 26 ans est-ce que est-ce que pour
vous c'est vraiment utile est-ce que ce
facteur prix
est nécessaire c'est utile pour pour
préservatif alors on sentait publique on
ne peut que se réjouir mais
effectivement on va le voir c'est pas
suffisant et effectivement il y a encore
des choses à faire pour éradiquer les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
et aussi les Russes du sida dans
quelques instants mais avant je tends un
petit à la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel le devrait rester couvert
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines prévoyait
des averses éparses durant la matinée au
niveau des températures il fera 11 à 12
degrés en moyenne dans l'après-midi pas
de grands changements en perspective le
ciel devrait rester couvert avec
quelques averses au niveau des
températures il fera 14 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 13 à Versailles et
Houdan et 12 degrés à Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons la saint Edward le
point maintenant sur l'actualité dans
les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous réginera lèche le 13
janvier prochain aura lieu le procès des
militants de Saclay oui deux activistes
seront jugés pour en travers la liberté
de travail le 15 octobre 2021 ces
derniers avaient déployé une banderole
sur une grue pour empêcher
l'urbanisation du plateau de Saclay
selon les militants ces dernières années
le plateau aurait perdu plus de 400
hectares de terres agricoles et la
construction de la ligne 18 du Métro
Grand Paris Express accélérerait le
phénomène le procès aura lieu au
tribunal judiciaire d'Evry un hommage
sera rendu à Clarissa Jean-Philippe la
brigadière de police tuée en 2015 lors
d'un attentat oui et c'est la ville de
Poissy qui lui rendra hommage ce
dimanche 8 ce dimanche 8 janvier à 11h
le dévoilement et le fleurissement d'une
plaque auront lieu en son honneur au
monument aux morts de la ville géant
Eric Winkler le sous-préfet de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye sera présent et la
galette des rois approche à grands pas
Régine et dans les Yvelines c'est la
chef pâtissière itomi Yamashita qui
décroche le prix de la meilleure galette
aux amandes dans la catégorie employée
installez en France depuis 9 ans la
japonaise dirige une boulangerie au
chant du coq à Versailles et si son nom
vous dit quelque chose c'est normal
puisqu'elle avait déjà remporté le prix
de la meilleure galette en 2019 et en
2021 et le chiffre du jour résine c'est
29 pourquoi on l'a appris aujourd'hui 29
c'est le nombre de candidats qui
défileront le 4 mars 2023 au théâtre de
Poissy pour l'élection Mister France
tout comme la célèbre émission Miss
France la soirée consistera à élire le
plus bel homme de France alors si vous
souhaitez assister à ce rendez-vous vous
pouvez vous inscrire sur le site
misterfrance.com et le premier bébé de
l'année dans les Yvelines est née à
Poissy le premier bébé de l'année 2023
dans les Yvelines est né à l'hôpital de
Poissy Gustave 3 kg 5 et 51 cm est né le
1er janvier à 1h58 le bébé se porte très
bien il mange bien et dors bien c'est le
bébé idéal selon commencer par en Solène
et Charles-Henri qui habite maison
Lafitte il jouera sûrement très
prochainement dans le parc de la commune
avec son grand frère Hector de 2 ans
soniny et vous voulez terminer par une
dernière information régime
effectivement donc pour ceux qui se
seraient inquiétés à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la nuit dernière
la lame du collège Giacometti à résonné
à cause d'un animal un chat serait à
l'origine de l'incident un seul est une
information assez insolite merci
beaucoup et si vous aussi vous voyez une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous le compte
à nous l'informer à nous en à nous le
communiquer pardon en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
et on continue de se plonger dans les
événements qui ont rythmé l'année 2022
cette fois-ci focus sur les mois de
juillet à septembre canicule Open de
France de golf ou encore big tour
Gabriel Gontier nous rafraîchit la
mémoire un été marqué par des chaleurs
records 33 jours de canicule les jeux
d'eau comme à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et les
piscines sont prisées au zoo de Thoiry
les soigneurs distribuent des sorbets et
smoothie aux animaux pour les rafraîchir
le député de la deuxième circonscription
Jean-Noël Barraud nommé ministre délégué
au numérique il laisse son siège à
l'Assemblée nationale à sa suppléante
anne-grignon suite à un recours elle ne
reste députée que quelques jours déjà
suppléante au Sénat les lune peut
cumuler les deux fonctions et
démissionne de nouvelles élections
partielles auront lieu en octobre une
mise en service très attendue celle du
tram T13 cette ligne relie en 30 minutes
l'école à Saint-Germain-en-Laye en août
le Sport reprend ses droits le FC
Versailles découvre le championnat de
National par une victoire au stade Jean
Bouin l'équipe s'impose de Buzyn contre
Martigues une belle lancée le
département haute des championnats du
monde de golf amateur par équipe c'est
au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et à
Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche 56 délégations
pour le tournoi d'âme 72 pour les
messieurs le golf à l'honneur de nouveau
fin septembre avec le retour de l'Open
de France à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
après deux ans d'absence 156 joueurs
présents l'italien Guido migliodis
adjuges 700 4e édition côté culture la
maison des Soeurs du domaine d'Ores à
château fort et sélectionné pour le loto
du patrimoine 2022 le monument du 19e
siècle va bénéficier d'une restauration
à hauteur de 129.000 euros une rentrée
en pleine inflation aux Mureaux
l’épicerie sociale ils avant à nouveau
des fournitures scolaires à des prix
réduits pour les familles en difficulté
au collège le département des Yvelines
des poissons cartes à bleu numérique
pour 130 000 jeunes et professeurs du
territoire des premiers jours de cours
particuliers pour les élèves de la
British School of Paris à
Croissy-sur-Seine deux minutes de
silence observées en hommage à la reine
Elizabeth II décédé à l'âge de 96 ans le
zoo de Thoiry a un nouveau pensionnaire
l'éléphanteau d'Afrique Moyo neuf ans
rejoint l'autre pachyderme du parc ben
âgé de 42 ans c'est le festival de
l'entreprise en France le Big tour de
BPI France fait étape au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
découverte de métiers recrutement
création d'entreprises et innovations au
programme de la journée et puis plus de
25000 coureurs prennent le départ du
mythique Paris Versailles la course
revient enfin après la pandémie de covid
19 une 43e édition remportée par Anaïs
Kenner chez les femmes côté homme une
grande première avec un versaillé
vainqueur juste en ourlant
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission
l'association Yvelines info jeune a
lancé en décembre dernier le dispositif
la boussole des jeunes avec nous pour en
parler Laurence cousin la directrice
d'Yvelines info Jeanne et Salamata
viennent au Mateta la présidente alors
première question c'est quoi cette
boussole des jeunes alors c'est quoi je
vais laisser Laurence répond là c'est
quoi cette boussole
numérique
qui s'adresse aux 15-30 ans et qui alors
quand on dit la boussole c'est des
boussole puisqu'en fait on choisit des
thématiques donc on a on a fait le choix
de la de la double thématique emploi et
formation
et donc quand le jeune va sur le site
boussole point
jeune.gouv.fr il lui suffit de mettre
son code postal et d'accéder soit s'il a
besoin d'une formation à l'espace
formation soit l'espace emploi et là il
y a un questionnaire qui va permettre
d'affiner sa demande et son besoin pour
le diriger vers le professionnel qui va
pouvoir
la compagnie la valeur ajoutée de ce de
cette plateforme numérique c'est que le
jeûne à la garantie d'avoir un retour en
moins de 7 jours c'est 7 jours maximum
le délai est assez court alors il peut
ne pas avoir vouloir éventuellement
avoir ce cet accompagnement mais il aura
des informations mais non il est
coordonnées des structures qui peuvent
qui peuvent l'accompagner et alors
comment ça a été mis en place pourquoi
est-ce que c'est le territoire des
Mureaux qui a été sélectionné alors ça
ça m'intéresse alors effectivement bah
déjà je vous remercie pour votre
invitation et mettre en lumière ce
magnifique réseau info jeune que j'ai eu
plaisir de piloter de porter avec les 32
structures alors pourquoi tout d'abord
le ce projet initialement devait être
porté en 2020 mais malheureusement le
confinement a freiné ce projet et le
choix du territoire des Mureaux s'est
fait je pense parce que c'est un
territoire également dynamique et j'ai
le plaisir également d'être élu sur le
territoire et aussi présidente de la
Mission Locale donc ça fait un lien
quand même assez étroit et voilà je
pense que c'est parce que le territoire
est assez dynamique un territoire jeune
il y a la grande ville qui est Les
Mureaux mais bien sûr nous avons des
zones rurales et c'est important pour
nous en tout cas politiquement de porter
ce projet aussi vis-à-vis des jeunes du
secteur rural c'est important d'aller
vers eux voilà tout simplement et donc
vous avez parlé de la Mission Locale
donc vous êtes la présidente sous quels
sont les professionnels avec qui vous
travaillez justement sur cette boussole
des jeunes alors peut-être que Laurence
veut compléter oui tout à fait alors
déjà l'association a recruté donc on a
recruté une personne spécifiquement donc
Aurélie Ernaux qui est la référente sur
le déploiement de la boussole des jeunes
sur le sur le 78
et j'ai excusez-moi j'ai zappé la
question Quels sont les professionnels
c'est vrai que nous on travaille déjà
depuis l'association à plus de 45 ans
donc on est déjà en contact direct avec
les partenaires de ces thématique là
mais pas que donc on les connaît bien
donc l'idée c'est de recenser l'offre de
service sur ces 23 communes que
représente le territoire des Mureaux
donc on les connaît et après on cherche
aussi un petit peu
euh et donc on va les accompagner dans
un extranet pour qu'il puisse détailler
l'offre de service et donc là
aujourd'hui c'est une première étape
puisqu'il inauguration a eu lieu le 14
décembre dernier donc c'est vraiment une
première étape et là on a déjà plus
d'une vingtaine de partenaires et c'est
une cinquantaine d'offres de services
quelles sont ses partenaires justement
alors il peut y avoir bah Pôle emploi la
Mission Locale bien entendu un cercies
plein d'autres NQT donc nos quartiers
ont du talent territoire à zéro chômage
enfin tous les acteurs en tout cas qui
sont dynamiques sur le territoire des
Mureaux donc effectivement aussi bien
associatif que finalement institutionnel
comme le Pôle Emploi donc c'est vraiment
je pense c'est également la richesse en
fait de ce territoire là c'est vrai
qu'on a quand même l'habitude de
travailler déjà de façon naturelle avec
tous les partenaires possibles donc ça
s'inscrit naturellement j'ai envie de
dire dans ce partenariat donc
une plateforme pour regrouper tous ces
services tout à fait vous aviez
l'impression que les jeunes étaient un
peu perdu vous n'avez pas connaissance
c'est vrai que l'intérêt c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de dispositifs qui sont
effectivement méconnus et puis les
jeunes aussi il faut aller vers les
jeunes on voit aujourd'hui on le
constate tout partenaire confondu
qu'effectivement il faut vraiment aller
vers et donc la plateforme numérique
c'est bien parce que le jaune il peut à
minuit 1h regarder sur internet et puis
prendre un contact donc ça c'est
essentiel et puis c'est vrai qu'on a
cité peut-être les structures les plus
connues mais c'est aussi intéressant de
voir les structures moins connues et
notamment associative je pense à la
Profession Sport et vie associative qui
va rejoindre le dispositif ils ont un
dispositif qui s'appelle sésame qui
permet à des jeunes de financer des
formations dans le domaine du sport donc
vous voyez c'est aussi ça c'est vraiment
cité Pôle emploi la Mission locale c'est
assez connu mais il y a d'autres
structures qui ne sont beaucoup moins et
il y a des dispositifs qui peuvent
vraiment être accessibles à ces jeunes
et donc c'est vraiment tout l'objectif
et l'enjeu de ce dispositif là et puis
au delà des partenaires mais qui sont
essentiels bien sûr pour faire vivre la
plateforme des partenaires à qui ont une
des services et aussi les ambassadeurs
l'idée c'est aussi tous les
professionnels qui s'adressent aux
jeunes de près ou de loin donc on a mis
on a des goodies c'est aussi l'idée de
communiquer parce que juste un tout
petit peu il faut il faut communiquer
effectivement pour faire connaître cette
plateforme donc voilà un taux de bag il
y a un carnet il y a de la documentation
qui est à disposition des professionnels
pour qu'ils puissent aussi effectivement
communiquer sur ce nouvel cette nouvelle
plateforme numérique et alors il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui n'ont pas de
réponse à leur offre d'emploi est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous faites sur
la boussole des jeunes mettre en
relation les jeunes avec ces entreprises
alors non parce que autrement si vous
voulez j'allais dire excusez-moi
l'expression c'est un peu certaines
usine à Garga c'est à dire qu'il y a des
professionnels nous l'idée c'est
vraiment de créer des passerelles de
recréer éventuellement des passerelles
avec les structures pour qu'il puisse
être accompagnés parce que des
plateformes il y a emploi store enfin il
y a plein de choses extraordinaires donc
on va pas refaire la même chose si on
mettait les offres d'emploi par exemple
sur la plateforme serait pas forcément
un grand intérêt mais souvent les gens
n'y pensent qu'ils ont tous sur internet
alors que le fait d'être accompagné par
un professionnel qui a du réseau qui
connaît les autres partenaires ça permet
de créer du lien et ça peut permettre
aussi de remettre le pied voilà dans
dans une entreprise pourquoi pas mais
c'est vrai que c'est c'est plutôt ça
l'objectif c'est de recréer du lien et
des passerelles entre les jeunes et les
structures qui peuvent accompagner ces
jeunes merci beaucoup à Régine vos avis
une question et jusqu'à quel âge on est
jeune justement
sur ce dispositif là jusqu'à 30 ans
voilà bonne raison Information Jeunesse
aussi c'est vrai que on est plus sur
2016 25 même si voilà c'est souvent
encore le cas sur les dispositifs mais
maintenant les dispositifs vont jusqu'à
29 30 ans et là c'est le cas 30 ans
super vous êtes concernés
[Rires]
et
Salamata vient ce matin d'être venu en
parler avec nous si vous êtes intéressé
par ce dispositif n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre directement sur le site internet
boussole.gouv.fr cela concerne aussi les
jeunes mais dans un autre domaine depuis
le 1er janvier les préservatifs
masculins sont désormais gratuits en
pharmacie pour les moins de 26 ans une
autre catégorie de jeunes une annonce du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron avec nous pour en parler Jérôme
André le directeur d'achève prévention
santé alors première question comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour en bénéficier de
ses préservatifs gratuits c'est assez
simple vous pouvez donc vous rendre à
partir du moment où vous avez moins de
26 ans dans n'importe quelle pharmacie
et puis vous seront proposés donc deux
boîtes de préservatifs soit les Eden
soit les Polaris donc là il y a des
marques les Polaris d'ailleurs c'est un
côté nostalgique aussi pour HF
prévention puisque c'est
l'une des marques dont le parrain est
Christophe Dechavanne qui pendant des
années a réclamé à ce que le préservatif
soit gratuit faut croire
qu'effectivement Emmanuel Macron a
entendu puisque c'est lui qui a permis
notamment d'avoir un coup extrêmement
faible extrêmement bas pour justement
que les jeunes puissent avoir des
préservatifs limites un peu gratuit il
était faire de lance de ça et le
président de la République a dû
l'entendre puisque les préservatifs
aujourd'hui sont complètement gratuits
en pharmacie pour les moins de 26 ans il
suffit d'avoir quand on a entre 18 et 26
ans une carte vitale et si vous n'avez
pas de carte vitale et que vous avez
moins de 18 ans vous avez le droit de
vous présenter en pharmacie on vous
remettra effectivement donc une boîte
les contours sont encore un peu floues
aujourd'hui puisque dans la
précipitation l'annonce des manuels
Macron a été faite mais il y a pas eu de
directives très clairs qui ont été
posées mais il semblerait que ce soit
une boîte par jour et donc comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour pour se faire
rembourser alors en fait on se fait pas
rembourser c'est-à-dire que simplement
on en pharmacie on présente la carte
Vitale si on est majeur moins de 26 ans
si on est mineur on vous la remet comme
ça et ensuite on vous la remet et merci
au revoir les pharmaciens doivent
néanmoins avoir la possibilité de
pouvoir aussi expliquer aux jeunes et
avoir un peu un petit entretien avec eux
notamment sur comment est-ce qu'on pose
le préservatif et que ça pourrait
effectivement
comment dire
déclencher un entretien de santé
sexuelle je suis pas convaincu
effectivement que ça fonctionne comme ça
c'est d'ailleurs le regret que nous on a
c'est que pourquoi les moins de 26 ans
là on voit dans le dispositif de la
boussole c'est les moins de 30 ans et
puis HF prévention avait fait d'ailleurs
un plaidoyer auprès du ministère de la
Santé et d'Emmanuel Macron parce qu'au
départ c'était les 18-26 ans et ils ont
ils n'inclué pas donc les mineurs tout
comme nous ce qu'on dit aussi c'est que
tout le monde n'a pas de carte vitale et
pourtant il nous apparaît nécessaire de
pouvoir effectivement le donner d'une
manière très large cette réforme fait
suite à une réforme effectivement qu'il
avait déjà proposé il y a deux ans où on
pouvait effectivement aller chez son
médecin et demander une ordonnance pour
avoir deux boîtes par an félicitons-nous
effectivement de cette nouvelle réforme
mais c'est pas suffisant parce qu'en
réalité on le voit et on le voit
d'autant plus à HF prénom puisque
aujourd'hui on fait sur l'année donc
2022 qu'on vient de quitter on a réalisé
plus de 16000 dépistages du VIH et des
IST en université puisque effectivement
on travaille sur l'ensemble des
universités d'Île-de-France mais pas
seulement et en général vous ne
connaissez bien
faciliter ou en tout cas de ralentir
les maladies mais le problème de la
santé sexuelle c'est que c'est pas que
un problème d'outils c'est aussi un
problème de de discussion avec les gens
de pouvoir effectivement modifier les
comportements de nos jeunes aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui imaginent
que le préservatif c'est aussi quand on
leur dit mais est-ce que tu mets un
préservatif ils nous disent bah non
c'est bon ma copine en l'occurrence
prend la pilule donc je n'ai pas besoin
de mettre de préservatif or en réalité
le préservatif certes est un moyen de
contraception parmi tant d'autres mais
c'est aussi et avant tout un moyen de se
prémunir des infections sexuellement
transmissibles du virus du sida qui
malheureusement sont en plein boom nous
on le constate sur nos chiffres 16000
dépistages donc et j'ai sorti les
chiffres Île-de-France et j'ai fait un
focus sur les Yvelines puisqu'on est
dans le 7 8 et que ça nous intéresse on
est à 64% d'IST sur chaque dépistage
donc rendez-vous compte à chaque fois
qu'on dépiste on des pistes des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
donc il y a une vraie urgence à pouvoir
agir et sur le fait d'élargir encore le
préservatif gratuit mais aussi les deux
de pouvoir permettre aux gens d'avoir de
l'information en santé sexuelle et comme
vous ne connaissez bien on a voulu
répondre ça avec effectivement plus de
300 professionnels de santé puisqu'on a
créé Sacha qui est la première
intelligence artificielle
conversationnelle et aujourd'hui ça
montre bien le besoin puisque Sacha
réalise 25 000 conversations chaque mois
chaque mois il y a effectivement 25000
conversations qui sont réalisées et là
on est vraiment dans de la haute couture
si je puis dire ça un site de la haute
couture sur de la prévention puisque
Sacha répond vraiment aux besoins des
jeunes en matière donc de prévention
c'est ça qui sera intéressant ça sera
effectivement de démultiplier la
prévention le dépistage et pas seulement
de rendre un outil gratuit même si ça
reste nécessaire et alors la rédaction
de TV 78 s'est rendu à la rencontre des
jeunes pour leur poser la question si
pour eux c'était une bonne chose la
gratuité des préservatifs les propos
recueillis par Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude et Ludivine canard j'ai entendu
parler sur les réseaux et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment top parce que ça
permet à tous de se protéger de des
enfants et également des maladies
vraiment je trouve que c'est une bonne
idée et puis il y a des gens qui osent
pas forcément en acheter qui ont pas
l'argent ou enfin c'est tout combien il
y en a leurs parents ils vérifient un
peu leur compte et bah du coup ils ont
un peu par ils ont pas très envie que
leurs parents le savent et donc ils
osent pas et donc ils prennent des
risques après ce que je vais l'utiliser
je sais pas ça va dépendre surtout bah
de la qualité de ce qu'ils vont donner
en soi mais comme c'est gratuit ouais je
pense c'est une très bonne chose bah
pour ceux qui ont pas les moyens de
s'enfourner et même pour les autres ça
peut faire des économies etc non je
pense que c'est bien parce que
peut-être il y a ce côté aussi un peu
tabou d'acheter des préservatifs en
magasin qui fait que potentiellement
certains stress règnent dans ce genre
d'achat on peut pas dire ah bah j'avais
pas d'argent j'en ai pas acheté on peut
pas on pourra pas il y a pas d'excuse
possible donc c'est une bonne chose
alors on vient de l'entendre les jeunes
sont plutôt contents mais la question du
prix a clairement un impact Jérôme la
question du prix un impact mais aussi le
lieu c'est-à-dire que en vrai et là on
le voit effectivement dans le
micro-trottoir il y a des jeunes qui
pensent que on va pouvoir le trouver
dans des magasins il aurait plus-value
aussi permettre que quand on va dans une
grande surface ou une supérette et bien
qu'on puisse avoir ce dispositif de
gratuité n'importe où n'importe quand
c'est ça qui est ennuyeux c'est
qu'effectivement il ne faut pas donc
imaginer que tout le monde ira en
pharmacie pour pouvoir avoir des
préservatifs gratuits donc quid de
l'accès parce que effectivement donc
dans les supermarchés ça aurait été
intéressant quid effectivement de la
limite de l'âge pour le coup 26 ans
c'est un peu dommage et puis pour les
gens qui n'ont pas de carte vitale ça
reste aussi dommageable et puis encore
une fois plus de discussions l'éducation
à la santé sexuelle ça doit démarrer
avec l'Éducation nationale aujourd'hui
c'est quand même malheureux qu'en France
il n'y ait que deux heures qui soit donc
mise à disposition là-dessus à condition
déjà qu'elle soit faite et croyez moi
c'est pas le cas partout notamment y
compris en Île-de-France et on se bat
beaucoup avec la région Île-de-France et
notamment Valérie Pécresse dans le cadre
de l'Île-de-France sensida pour
permettre il y ait encore plus mais
c'est pas le cas encore aujourd'hui et
on le voit il y a vraiment donc des
besoins sur les modifications de
comportement des gens parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour eux les infections
sexuellement transmissibles c'est tout
aussi invisible que le virus du sida et
ça pose des vrais problèmes je le dis si
vous ne vous faites pas des pister d'une
infection sexuellement transmissible
vous pouvez avoir des vrais problèmes ça
ne se voit pas et vous pouvez avoir donc
des cancers être stériles etc etc et
c'est bien dommageable alors qu'en fait
on a un arsenal qui permettrait de
pouvoir guérir puisque pour certaines
infections sexuellement transmissibles
on guérit merci beaucoup Jérôme André
d'être venu en parler avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes le directeur d'achève
prévention santé on retrouve en visio à
distance Irène Perrault vous êtes
responsable des espaces verts à Poissy
et justement vous allez nous parler un
peu de ces chèvres qui sont à adopter au
hameau de la reine alors est-ce que déjà
vous pouvez nous expliquer dans quel
état est-ce arriver ces chèvres et
combien est-ce qu'il y en a
alors il y en a une grande quantité
il y a beaucoup de bêtes à adopter
elles sont dans des états comment dire
un petit peu
le bien-être animal est là
et donc du coup elles sont dans des
états un petit peu
un petit peu de chacun il y en a qui ont
des pâtes cassées il y en a d'autres qui
sont pas entretenus on voit que c'est
des bêtes qui ont un peu souffert et
donc du coup elles attendent que de
l'amour
et donc comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
les adopter ces chèvres alors adopter
une chèvre c'est pas un acte anodin il
faut déjà à peu près 1000 mètres carrés
pour une chèvre et surtout bien faire
attention de faire des bons enclos
parce que les chèvres adorent s'en aller
aller voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
ailleurs mais toujours meilleur
et alors je crois qu'il faut aussi les
adopter par deux on ne peut pas adopter
une chèvre toute seule sinon elle serait
trop triste il faut qu'elle soit deux
c'est comme nous en fait on aime la
compagnie ben c'est pareil
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses à
savoir comment enfin qu'est-ce qu'il
faut pour les nourrir qu'est-ce qu'on
doit leur donner
sachant que un enclos d'herbe pour m²
quand je disais pour une pour une seule
veste donc ça serait 2000 pour deux
qu'il faut séparer en deux parce qu'en
fait elle grignote un peu partout donc
si on ne sait pas en deux ça va pouvoir
permettre de laisser pousser l'herbe
d'un côté
et comme ça elles auront toujours un peu
de d'herbes fraîches toujours mettre du
foin à disposition
et sachant qu'une chèvre ça peut boire
jusqu'à 10 litres d'eau
d'accord donc
c'est assez conséquent et ce qu'il faut
toujours être présent sur place ou
est-ce qu'on peut les laisser un peu
vivre leur vie
non elles ont pas besoin de nous
réellement en fin de compte en fait
c'est du moment que vous mettez la
quantité de c'est compatible de
nourriture suffisante elle se débrouille
et vous pouvez partir un week-end
tranquillement à la campagne par exemple
et alors Salamata vient de ce matin à
une question un plateau elle se demande
si c'est compatible avec des chiens
bonne question
[Rires]
après tout dépend de la race du chien
d'accord et Jérôme André vous avez
également une question
ces chefs sont à adopter et pourquoi
elles sont dans cet état-là enfin moi je
suis assez surpris en fait que il y ait
effectivement des chèvres qui soient
dans un dans un piteux état et il s'est
passé quoi alors je vous laisse répondre
je vais pas la réponse
pourquoi pourquoi ces chèvres enfin ça a
été suite à une alerte de maltraitance
qui a été c'était dans un autre
département il me semble
oui oui je crois que ça a été ça en fin
de compte et se passer sur pas mal de
réseaux sociaux
pour essayer au maximum de les adopter
pour pour les sauver en fin de compte
un abandon
ce sont pas des chefs du hameau de la
reine ce sont des chèvres qui ont enfin
que le hameau de la reine a bien voulu
héberger pour pour en attendant qu'elle
soit adoptée voilà
et bien merci beaucoup Irène Perrault
d'être venu répondre à nos questions en
visio on va passer maintenant à notre
bonne soirée on va passer maintenant à
notre page au cinéma
et on commence par le coup de cœur
cinéma d'un professionnel cette semaine
c'est le réalisateur Gauthier Bara qui
vous propose son coup de cœur regardez
[Musique]
c'est une famille avec plusieurs enfants
ils sont dans la montagne en restaurant
en altitude il va y avoir ce qu'on
appelle une avalanche contrôlée donc ce
sont des gens qui vont déclencher une
balance sauf que ça ta Valence contre
les n’est pas si contrôlé que ça
il va arriver au rat de ce restaurant en
altitude dans lequel est la famille à ce
moment-là le père prend son portable
court se protéger et la mère saute sur
les enfants à ce moment-là on arrive sur
un drame familial
[Musique]
il y a ce qu'on appelle un non dit tout
au long du film très très peu de
dialogue mais je pense ça a été un des
premiers films sur lequel le silence est
une règle d'or et elle le plus présent
dans le cinéma mondial
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la règle du père
protecteur qui éclate on peut parler
concrètement de hors-piste du cinéma
avec une musique en fait qui revient
régulièrement qui est la
musique de l'hiver des Quatre Saisons de
Vivaldi et qui est l'unique musique qui
est utilisé au sein de ce film c'est un
travail sur le comportement humain et de
ses réactions un effondrement du couple
du silence qui pose lourd un
renforcement sur eux-mêmes sur les
personnages
[Musique]
c'est un peu l'horreur du réel et on
peut parler concrètement d'une
expérience sociale
[Musique]
et on poursuit cette page au cinéma avec
vous mais quel ennemi de robes bonsoir
vous allez nous parler des films à ne
pas manquer en 2023 et on va tout de
suite commencer par un film qui vient
qui vient de sortir en salle ce mercredi
4 janvier son nom tirailleurs dans le
rôle principal on retrouve le trappiste
de 44 ans Omar Sy le synopsis en 1917
Bakary Diallo s'enroule dans l'armée
française pour rejoindre son fils de 17
ans recruté pour participer à la
première guerre mondiale envoyé sur le
front père et fils vont affronter la
guerre ensemble avec des objectifs
différents une belle histoire de famille
avec en toile de fond une page
historique on regarde un extrait
incorporer africain du haut Niger du
Sénégal de la Guinée du Soudan vous
allez contribuer à cet éclatante
victoire
[Musique]
après cette bataille vous ne serez plus
des indigènes vous serez des Français
et il aura également un film Marvel à ne
pas manquer cette année Michael oui
c'est ant Man 3 ou Ant-Man et la guêpe
quand tu Mania la sortie prévue le 15
février prochain le film racontera
toujours l'histoire de Scotland et hop
vandin le duo va explorer la dimension
subatomique sur le royaume quantique et
ses mystères ils vont aussi devoir faire
face à l'un des plus dangereux individus
du multivers kangle conquérant c'est
pour cela que le film est très attendu
par les fans de Marvel on le regarde un
extrait
[Musique]
c'est quoi cet endroit
c'est un univers caché à l'intérieur
d'une autre
de quoi tu as peur
je ne vous ai pas tout dit et on
continue avec un film plutôt grand
public si je vous dis un village
d'irréductible Gaulois résiste encore et
toujours à l'envahisseur vous me prenez
quoi Mathilde
et bien oui Astérix et Obélix l'Empire
du Milieu va sortir le premier février
prochain dans les acteurs on retrouvera
à Guillaume Canet originaire de plaisir
Gilles Lellouche l'ancien attaquant du
PSG Zlatan Ibrahimovic ou encore Vincent
Cassel l'histoire se déroulera en 50
avant Jésus-Christ l'impératrice de
Chine est emprisonnée suite à un coup
d'état sa fille demande de l'aide à
Astérix et Obélix qui accepte les
Romains seront également de la partie
avec César et ça puissante armé ça donne
très envie d'aller le voir votre
quatrième choix Michael se porte sur le
film Barbie je sais que vous l'attendez
avec impatience un Mathilde intitulé
Barbie le film réalisé par Greta garwin
sortir en juillet 2023 le long métrage
racontera l'histoire de la fameuse
poupée elle vient d'être expulsée de et
se retrouve dans le monde humain pour
chercher le vrai bonheur Barbie sera
joué par Margot Robbie il y aura
également Ryan Gosling dedans on regarde
un extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
effectivement un film bien déjanté que
j'ai bien envie d'aller voir au cinéma
et enfin on termine par un film qui
sortira en février Michael oui le 22
février très précisément the fabelman
sera réalisé par Steven Spielberg
racontera l'histoire du jeune Samy
fabelmann qui rêve de devenir
réalisateur c'est un biopic de 2h31
minutes ce qui est intéressant c'est que
cette autobiographie s'inspire de la
propre jeunesse du cinéaste un projet
très personnel pour Steven Spielberg
qu'il avait en tête depuis de nombreuses
années le film a fait un carton en
avant-première au festival international
du film de Toronto 2022 où il a remporté
le prix du public et pour les puristes
de musique de film c'est John Williams
qui a travaillé sur le projet merci
beaucoup Mickaël Midor est-ce que bah
autour du plateau Mickaël Régine vous
avez une préférence pour l'un de ses
films ou est-ce que un autre film pour
vous c'est le film de l'année 2023
j'ai vraiment tous envie de les voir
peut-être Ant-Man un peu moins que les
autres vous n'êtes pas trop Marvel ouais
non pas trop mais sinon oui c'est vrai
que tous les autres tirailleurs je pense
que c'est intéressant de de se pencher
dessus Barbie pour mon enfance Astérix
et Obélix pareil et Spielberg ouais
enfin ouais je suis très intéressé vous
mettez je pense que c'est Ant-Man 3
exactement c'est ce que j'ai dit après
précédemment mais tous les films que
j'ai présenté ont l'air très très bien
voir aussi c'est open Heimer c'est avec
l'acteur de de Peaky blinders c'est sur
comment était créé la bombe atomique en
fait pendant pendant la guerre froide
donc c'est un film un peu historique que
j'aimerais bien découvrir également de
beaux films en tout cas en 2023
découvrez au cinéma exactement
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant je vous propose de
jeter un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel le devrait rester couvert
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines prévoyait
des averses épars durant la matinée au
niveau des températures il fera 11 à 12
degrés en moyenne dans l'après-midi pas
de grands changements en perspective le
ciel devrait rester couvert avec
quelques averses au niveau des
températures il fera 14 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie très à Versailles et
Houdan et 12 degrés à Rambouillet et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]